[Música]
gente eu trouxe um problema muito grave
para compartilhar com vocês muito grave
mas ao mesmo tempo invisível invisível
porque a gente nunca acha que essas
coisas vão acontecer com a gente né
então a gente deixa passar na minha
opinião isso tinha que ser tratado nas
escolas
eu vim falar sobre violência doméstica
talvez se a gente tivesse conversado um
pouco mais eu não tivesse passado por
isso
no meu caso foi eu tive um
relacionamento abusivo tanto moral tanto
quanto psicológico quanto físico e as
pessoas perguntam já é se kan
você é uma menina estudada educada como
é que você sujeito a isso pois é simples
né
por que você não foi embora no primeiro
tapa por que você não foi embora quando
ele chegou pela primeira vez ea resposta
é tão simples quanto essa pergunta
porque eu não sabia
é gente eu simplesmente não sabia então
eu sofri humilhação de todos os tipos
eu tomei cusparada na cara ele e me
humilhava de todas as formas ele mandava
ajoelhar e eu não tinha feito algo que
ele que ele tinha pedido pra fazer como
uma forma de perdão tinha que olhar o
rastejar
ele atacava copo de água na minha cara
toda vez que a gente conversava e eu
tinha que prestar atenção no que ele
estava falando
pois é eu não sabia
eu fui condicionada a pensar que era
normal que a culpada de tudo aquilo era
eu e eu fiz isso por que ele fez isso
porque eu merecia porque eu estava muito
e eu realmente acreditava eu falava e eu
preciso melhorar eu preciso evoluir ele
falava pra mim direta
jéssica eu sei que eu trato mal mas
você quer que eu mude você tem que mudar
sua atitude
assim que eu fiquei sendo condicionado
bom acho importante contar pra vocês eu
queria explicar um pouquinho porque só
nessa história num não fica somente
comigo essa história pode estar
representada em todos vocês
então eu queria muito contar pra vocês
como é que acontece essa evolução desse
relacionamento
e pra isso eu vou mostrar com a minha
história eu acho que muitas pessoas vão
se identificar com isso bom começando
falando sobre mim
a primeira coisa que vou fazer pra
começar a falar sobre mim é de cd se
sala
pronto agora faço com essa conversa com
vocês direito
gente eu tenho 28 anos eu sou formado em
administração de empresas
eu sou viajada morei fora é trabalho
como modelo já foi empresária só criada
em uma família maravilhosa eu tenho paz
incríveis tenham irmãos maravilhosos e
sempre tive um sonho de casar e ter
filhos aquela coisa de de filme né
agora falando um pouquinho do fulano
vocês não têm noção do que é esse cara é
o cara mais lindo que já vi na minha
vida ele era o cara mais incrível para
mim eu colocava ele em cima de um
pedestal juro era surreal que dava pra
ele um pedaço de madeira
o cara voltava com uma mesa e duas
cadeiras sério tinha habilidade qualquer
coisa que pedi pra ele fazer e fazia com
uma super excelência sério dá um peixe
cru para ele vinha com uma barca de
sushi com ovas enfim até o quadrado fica
do recife mais exigente mas ele chegava
com isso pois é e aí um dia a jessica
conhecer o fulano
aí a gente entra na primeira parte
no nosso primeiro passo de um
relacionamento abusivo a parte que ele
faz você se apaixonar como ninguém a
parte é que ele faz você acreditar que
você encontrou a pessoa certa e que vai
ficar assim para sempre que vai ser a
coisa mais feliz do mundo e que o mundo
inteiro tem que estudar
de e pra você ficar e viver uma linda
história de amor é ele e nunca eu nunca
conheci alguém tão tão incrível quanto
ele é não ser a quem olhava a gente nas
redes sociais falava um casal perfeito
também achava que era o casal perfeito
era tudo lindo tudo lindo era viagens é
alta as declarações de amor era uma
coisa maravilhosa pois é aí a gente
entra no nosso segundo passo segundo
passo
o agressor ele mina todas as fortalezas
da vítima pois é então ele começa de uma
forma sutil a eu acho que você não tem
que pensar mais na sua família do
passado tem que pensar na família que a
gente vai construir no futuro
só nós dois importa a mas eu acho que
você não tem que sair com suas amigas
porque suas amigas elas têm inveja de
você na verdade a mas eu acho que você
não precisa trabalhar você tem que viver
comigo e eu te sustenta dentro nenhum e
eu achava isso lindo achava maravilhoso
nossa cara é a vida eu sou eu não quero
nada não quero sair com as amigas eu não
quero ver minha família não quero mais
nada eu só quero ele e é lógico né gente
um alvo isolado é muito mais fácil de
ser controlado
foi assim eu lembro que em uma viagem
que a gente fez com a família
passei muito tempo com eles e ela ele
ficou nervoso ele ficou muito bravo e
ele veio pra mim brigando porque você
não tem que ficar com sua família tem
que ficar comigo eu sou família e aí
falei puxa amor desculpa eu não sabia
que você se incomodou com isso desculpa
a ele é não desculpa não se você está
arrependida mesmo então ajoelha eu achei
que aquilo fosse uma brincadeira na
verdade tudo que eu queria era sempre
deixar que as coisas ficassem bem eu não
estava importando o que eu ia fazer eu
queria ficar bem com ele então ajoelhei
a itabom vai a brincadeira tá bom vai te
deixar mais feliz a gente vai ficar bem
vamos então tá ajoelhei e quando o
joelho e ele falou assim não não não
quero que seja joelho e só quero que
você rasteja aí eu fui lá e rastejei foi
pronta e agora tudo bem
tá tudo bem então pronto acabou foi a
primeira vez que fiz isso e eu sendo
muito sincero eu não tinha noção do que
estava fazendo
não tinha noção do tamanho disso o que
isso ia se tornar um bom a gente entra
no terceiro passo
3º passo onde entra as agressões verbais
e nesse lugar onde a gente está agora é
eu sou completamente dependente dele
eu me afastei da minha família me
afastei dos meus amigos me afastei é do
meu trabalho
então a gente começa a depender
financeiramente a gente começa a
depender emocionalmente em todos os
sentidos
ele começa a agredir verbalmente de uma
forma sutil no começo como por exemplo o
amor deixa que eu cozinho para a gente
porque você não sabe fazer nada direito
né amor deixa que eu faço isso porque
você não sabe fazer eu sei fazer melhor
que você
essa forma sutil né está gordinha vamos
academia ele ficava do meu lado
acelerando a esteira para ocorrer porque
estava gordinho sério aí começam as
agressões começa isso começa a evoluir
as agressões começam a ficar mais graves
mais graves e entra a psicóloga uma
violência psicológica mais forte como eu
vou te deixar eu simplesmente vou te
deixar você não serve pra mim ele já
sabia que dependia dele em todos os
sentidos já e que precisava dele
praticamente para respirar
ele falava eu vou te deixar eu não quero
mais você você você é um lixo só não
serve pra mim porque eu sou um lixo
porque você não muda o jeito que você me
trata você não você não limpa direito
você não cozinha direito você não faz
nada direito então eu vou embora ele e
embora ele fazia mala e embora eu ia
atrás dele pelo amor de deus não vai
embora não sei viver sem você eu não sei
ficar sem você por favor fica comigo
fica comigo ou ele me mandava embora
eles do nada falava assim a jessica não
dá mais as casa minha então vai embora
mas o
pra onde não sei se vira eu perdi o
número de vezes de contas de quantas
vezes eu já dormi dentro do carro para
não precisar voltar para casa dos meus
pais e eles vão pra que eles não
soubessem o que estava passando dormir
dentro do carro quando voltava para casa
dos meus pais e foi inventada que eu era
louca que eu tinha enfim é feito um
escarcéu que a culpa era sempre minha
mas pra falar a verdade sempre tinha às
vezes vinham os momentos de lucidez e eu
falava não isso aqui não está certo isso
aqui não tá certo sempre fui criada com
muito amor
não é possível não é possível dar certo
e aí eu ia pra casa dos meus pais eu
falava assim
pelo amor de deus não me deixa voltar
àquela vida e aí logo no dia seguinte
chegava a jéssica submissa na outra
outro lado da minha cabeça eu preciso
desse cara para inspirar
eu preciso não vivo sem ele eu preciso
dele e aí assim eu voltava nem fala mais
se falando você falou para mim não
deixar se voltar e aí eu vá e pelo amor
de deus tem 30 anos na cara né o deixa
eu voltava é eu sei o que eu faço eu sei
enfim aquilo era tudo muito novo a gente
não as pessoas ao redor das vezes não
conseguem identificar
por isso é tão importante a gente
conversar sobre isso é tão importante a
gente tá luz e dá voz a esse assunto
porque às vezes as pessoas passam por
isso e a gente nem sabe às vezes nem a
própria pessoa está passando por isso
sabe
bom a gente entra no próximo passo que
pra mim é foi ou não parou e eu não sei
o que seria de mim depois graças a deus
eu consegui sair dessa mas a gente
entrou nas agressões físicas
então começa também de forma sutil a
pessoa se empurrando a pessoa puxa o
cabelo a pessoa chuta é enfim eu já
fiquei com diversos roxo já fui enganada
eu já fui e ele sem falar a mensagem que
eu te batendo o cara está falando de um
carro de dois metros de altura nessa
tentativa atendo jéssica pelo amor de
deus eu te bater se eu ia te matar
isso não é bater you é verdade ele não
tava batendo porque se eu fosse bater
lean
a minha cara isso não é bater imaginar
me empurra sempre roxo escondendo os
meus gols mas não não é bater
teve uma vez que eu estava dirigindo
porque é a minha única função era
dirigir o carro porque ele falava que
não fazer nada direito então eu tinha
que dirigia o carro e aí eu tivesse
cansado e pedisse pra ele dirigiu o
carro pra mim é moroso cansados por
dirigir pra mim era um assim um sem
nenhuma eu já vivia se não com medo eu
tenho assim tudo qualquer coisa assim
bom e aí eu passei em cima de um buraco
quando eu passei nesse buraco eram três
da manhã quando eu passei nesse buraco
ele ele falou assim já desce do carro
passou em um buraco e não vou descer do
carro e foi assim
sem dúvida este puxou pelo cabelo são
descer para 3 da manhã no meio da
juscelino kubischek eu falei não tá bom
isso deixa eu vou embora o meu ver não
está funcionando meu pai minha mãe
tiveram que me buscar e inventei a maior
história falei que eu dei a louca que eu
fui embora porque eu briguei com ele
enfim e eles acreditaram e foi assim que
que ficou outra vez eu é engraçado falar
pra vocês porque é literalmente isso eu
ficava super assim do seu favor da
língua isso aqui porque ele falou que eu
vou me trair ó tá limpo vão falar que eu
ia e voltava duas vezes para ver se
estava tudo certinho lugar não tá tudo
certo
será que não vai ficar bravo comigo não
vai tudo é assim qualquer coisa que eu
falar que eu tinha que ficar com muito
medo e eu tinha que ficar sozinha tenta
tenta tenta e vivia pisando em ovos teve
uma vez que eu coloquei os cachorros pra
dentro de casa sem lavar patinha e ele
tinha lavado a casa inteira ele falava
ele me empurrou no chão e falou assim
jéssica como é que você faz isso você
não respeita o meu trabalho agora vou te
mostrar como é que eu me sinto quando
você faz esse tipo de coisa aí eu falei
tá bom mas o que que é como que é que eu
fiz sem fim ele falou ele pegou foi até
o quarto abriu uma garrafa de austin
olhou na minha cara bem cínico vir oca a
garrafa e falou assim agora lindo com um
pano ajoelhe limpa
eu fui
ai meu deus do céu eu tentei tá bom tá
bom
ele levantou foi pegou o bituca de
cigarro jogou no chão agora limpo foi no
prato sujo pra tu lá agora limpo fui lá
ninguém
ele me empurrou a situação está a fazer
nada direito você não precisa nem para
limpar a casa vai pegar uma candidatura
olímpica
fui pegar candida quando cheguei para
pegar a criança não tinha candidato fez
sair às três da manhã para buscar a
candidata
onde é que eu achar cândidas três da
manhã
só sei que eu rodei a cidade só achei
uma padaria 24 horas aberto ele me
ligava cinco em cinco minutos se você
não voltar agora para casa voltar agora
para casa nunca mais voltasse nunca mais
voltar está ouvindo um horror é é assim
que eu me sentia bom como eu saí dessa
eu sair né
então aqui contando pra vocês é minha
mãe me obrigou a começar a fazer terapia
ela começou a sentir que alguma coisa
não estava certo
tinha alguma coisa errada comecei a
fazer terapia não deu um mês de terapia
terapeuta falou assim você está vivendo
uma situação de violência doméstica e
quase cai pra trás
eu jamais eu nunca tinha ouvido falar
nisso então ela falou assim eu preciso
que você vá nessa psiquiatra ela vai me
ajudar a tratar seu caso quando foi na
psiquiatra ela falou assim eu vou falar
com seus pais e foi num pelo amor de
deus não fala não está preparada para ir
embora eu amo ele não quer ou não quer
deixar ele não quero que ninguém saiba
por favor não fale me sentindo mal eu
acho que está atraindo ele fazendo isso
a ela eu vou falar com seus pais amanhã
às 7 da manhã eles estão aqui fomos na
às sete da manhã na na consulta ela
falou assim negócio seguinte ou seis
tiram a jéssica de casa à força se ela
não sair até amanhã por livre e
espontânea vontade
ou ele vai matar ela é o próximo passo
da violência doméstica que graças a deus
eu não cheguei é ele vai matar ela e aí
nesse mesmo dia a gente foi uma reunião
com os advogados e sabe que engraçado os
advogados falaram assim é eu estava tão
atordoado meu deus não quer embora não
quer ir embora tão atordoada e os
advogados irão pra mim falar assim e
jessica olha como as pessoas têm que
saber como falar
permitiu-se jessica está preocupada com
ele o eleitor está com medo de alguma
coisa acontece aconteça com ele o
eleitor
então faça o seguinte tem que sair de
casa hoje e se você não sai de casa ele
vai te matar e ele vai acabar com a vida
dele
aquilo foi mais forte pra mim aquilo
pegou mais meu deus ele vai se ferrar
não eu vou morrer
olha isso agora vocês me perguntam como
é que você se sente como é que você se
sentia né
nada melhor do que é mostrar assim ou
nada bege fazia sozinha
literalmente invisível não tinha mais
vontade de nada não tinha mais
não sabemos quem era jessica que já está
gostava que jessica não gostava
eu por exemplo vou levantar daqui vou
colocar a minha roupa de novo e vai ser
como se nada tivesse acontecido como se
a vida fosse perfeito né
ela é linda ela se veste bem ó amigo
incrível não é bem assim né pra vocês
que estão ouvindo isso que passam por
isso não tenho medo de falar
não tenho medo de conversar sobre isso
não tem problema a gente ter um ser
humano tem tem um negócio com o fracasso
né eu nunca tive esse problema eu não
tenho problema de falar que a gente
fracassa não tenho problema de mostrar
os pontos negativos
se vocês passam por isso num se sintam
mal em pedir ajuda em falar com as
pessoas que vocês amam é tão bom ser
cuidados e ajudado
então gente qual é o problema de vocês é
a primeira pessoa a levantar a mão e
falar que tá com medo
você vai ajudar outras pessoas esse vai
com certeza se a ajudar se auto ajudar
isso chama-se soro
idade obrigada gente
[Aplausos]